back in the mid-90s Microsoft wonder
windows 95 in every home that's why I
hired friend stars Matthew Perry and
jennifer anderson to teach people at the
sexy fun world of the PC operating
system and could it be any more
hilarious ok now let's load up the
taskbar I'll show you what it does cash
bar is that anything like Snickers bar
love have nougat what is nougat does
anybody know that oh Jesus this lady's
like god damn it I knew we should have
gotten Frazier why we doing that's not
their fault comedian friends Eponine you
know they did this corporate gig they
probably got paid a ton of money like
well no one's ever gonna see this this
looks like it's 50 years ago like
Jennifer Aniston looks like a Puerto
Rican bank teller bad at math like what
if you fell right now do you see II I
know comedian friends episodes were
always titled things like the one where
Joey moves out or the one with the
chicken pox what is this episode called
Jamie the one where Rachel dates a
Nigerian prince yeah just to help him
transfer the money yeah Michelle um this
is the one actually where she finds out
that John voids daughter is gonna steal
her man later Rio know that works out
great